dans le domaine médical une équipe de
chirurgie à allemand vient de réaliser
une prouesse technologique qui est aussi
une première mondiale
ces médecins est implanté sur un patient
à coeur artificiel qui fonctionne sans
câble ni fils explications avec jean
daniel flaysakier c'est le dernier né
des coeurs artificiels tout en titane 1
kg 6 il remplace le ventricule gauche
chez un patient dans le coeur ne
fonctionne plus il permet d'attendre
plusieurs mois que la greffe et mais il
a surtout un gros avantage sa batterie
est implanté sous la peau
plus besoin de câbles qui dépasse et
donc moins de risques d'infection le
chargeur se porte à la ceinture et on
peut l'enlever deux fois par jour 20
minutes à chaque fois de quoi prendre
une douche par exemple la qualité de vie
est grandement améliorée ce dispositif
peut à mon avis remplacer un jour la
transplantation pour le coeur donc tout
va bien en revanche pour la cicatrice il
y a sans doute quelques petits progrès à
faire
jean daniel flaysakier cette greffe
artificielle apporte beaucoup d'espoir
il faut le dire aux patients notamment
donc ce à ceux qui attendent une greffe
du coeur
oui parce que les médecins allemands
peut-être dans l'euphorie de l'opération
10 pour certains un truc ça pourrait
même éviter d'avoir à greffer on a quand
même très loin de là mais en revanche il
est sûr que ça va permettre de patienter
vous savez qu'il ya un pragmatique
manque d'organes à greffer que c'est
vrai que c'est pas toujours facile pour
une famille dont un proche a décidé
d'axer de décider à accepter le
prélèvement et que plusieurs dizaines de
personnes voire plusieurs centaines en
europe meurent chaque année en attendant
un coeur donc là on sait qu'on pourra
dans de très bonnes conditions et
surtout grâce aux nouveaux systèmes
d'énergie permettre à ces gens
d'attendre des conditions moins moins
mauvaise qu'avant parce que là ya pas de
ya pas de câble qui revient easter ça
passe par induction à travers la peau
via liberté liberté peut même ils
peuvent se laver ce qui est quand même
me loi mais négligent alors l'autre
solution c'est la xénogreffe c'est ce
qu'on appelle des xénogreffes c'est
qu'on travaille beaucoup aujourd'hui sur
des organes des animaux qu'on humanise
ray entre guillemets et le port est le
premier candidat alors il ya tout un tas
de questions de sécurité qui se posent
évidemment on en a résolu une qui était
très importante il y avait 1
il ya un virus qui fait partie du
patrimoine génétique du port dont on
avait peur qu'il puisse un jour passés
chez l'humain des études récentes ont
montré qu'après douze ans de suivi on ne
retrouve jamais jamais ce virus chez les
personnes qui était encore en contact de
de tissus porcin en revanche si on
recommandera très probablement aux
personnes qui subiront un jour cette
greffe et ça le sera peut-être dans deux
trois ans d'éviter d'avoir des rapports
sexuels non protégés et d'éviter d'avoir
des enfants parce que on a toujours peur
d'une maladie qui pourraient se
transmettre et qu'on ne connaît pas un
dernier mot sur une éventuelle
opposition religieuse puisqu'on sait que
les juifs et les musulmans notamment en
turquie vis-à-vis de la grèce au coeur
de port un peu le porc est un animal qui
est donc la consommation est interdite
dans deux des trois religions du livre
dans la religion musulmane à l'horizon
juive alors actuellement les avis ne
sont pas exactement identique
le grand rabbin samuel sirat qui
travaille sur les questions d'éthique
dit que la religion juive n'interdira
pas la greffe à partir de porcs parce
que c'est la vie qui doit primer le
recteur dalil boubakeur de la mosquée de
paris pour l'instant à une position pas
très bien définis parce qu'il pose
effectivement le problème de l'interdît
mais je crois que le jour où loge où la
vie devra primer peut-être que certains
interdits religieux finiront par tomber
merci jean daniel